ANNOUNCER: Ladies and
gentlemen, Stephen Adams.
STEPHEN ADAMS: Hello.
Like you said,
I'm Stephen Adams.
I'm a member of the Dart
team in the Seattle office.
I work on the Dart JavaScript
compiler and the related
libraries.
What I want to achieve here
is to give you a few tools
for understanding how the
JavaScript code is compiled
to help you write
what I would like
to call seaworthy
applications, applications
that don't have performance
problems when you ship them.
So first, I'm going to
talk a little bit about how
we compile Dart to JavaScript.
And then, what are the
implications of that for how
you might write your programs?
So for efficiency
reasons, we want
to compile Dart types to
primitive JavaScript types
where possible.
Like Dart number should
be JavaScript numbers,
strings to strings, and
lists to JavaScript arrays.
So this means that we
have to deal with the fact
that these types not
always quite regular.
They don't all operate
in the same way.
So consider this
little program here,
we've got a call
to the add method.
If we knew that x was
a JavaScript array,
we could compile
that, and we want to,
and we can compile that
to the JavaScript push.
That's about the best
way of adding something
to a JavaScript array.
However, if we were to
run this code on a set,
all the sets in the core
library are written in Dart,
and they use Dart
calling conventions.
So we end up by
calling an add method,
and we put a little
thing on there, the $1
to enforce the Dart semantics.
Unlike JavaScript, in
Dart, if you call a method
with the wrong
number of arguments,
you get to no such method error.
The problem that the
compiler has to solve
is, what do we do when
both of these things
can happen at the same time?
Like any problem in
computer science,
we can solve it by adding an
extra level of indirection.
So what we do is we call this
getInterceptor function, which
returns a method
table for the object.
And then we call the add
method from the method table.
The getInterceptor method covers
over all of the irregularity
in the underlying Dart types.
And it looks like that.
The main thing I want to
say about that is it's
basically a case analysis of
all of the primitive JavaScript
objects to find their
equivalent Dart methods.
So it's relatively expensive
to do that case analysis
all of the time.
It's not as bad as it looks,
because JavaScript engines
do pretty well and
optimizing that kind of code.
They do well because, really,
it's exploiting the JavaScript
implementation hierarchy.
But nonetheless, we'd
like to do it less often,
so we use standard compiler
optimizations, for example,
hoisting this out of loops.
But it would be better yet
if we could avoid doing
this two level dispatch at all.
So how can we get rid of
the two level dispatch?
What we do is we
do type inference
to see if we can discover
when it's not necessary.
Type inference is an
iterative process,
a data flow algorithm where we
push types around the program.
And each point in
the program, we
accumulate the set of types that
could be used there in the hope
that that's useful.
So what are the characteristics
of type inference?
The first characteristic
is it's intraprocedural.
This is a whole program
optimization, whole program
analysis.
If we were to add to our program
a call to the add method here,
we would know that the
list is flowing into add.
So we know that
x is a list which
is represented by
a JavaScript array,
we know that the return
value is a JavaScript array,
and this flows into a.
Now, if iterative data flow
analysis came to a fixed point
at this point, and it had
stopped adding new types,
then what we would know is that
even though we didn't declare
anything, it's a
JavaScript array,
so we could generate
the call to push.
That would be ideal.
We'd generate the
best possible code.
However, it's not
always the case
that we get to
that kind of point.
For example, there might
be another call where
we call this method with a set.
New set is a factory constructor
which returns a linked HashSet.
So if we push this
linked HashSet
pipe around our
program, we'll notice
that this type information seems
to slosh around the program.
Though another characteristic
of the type inference
is that at some points, we
are not context sensitive.
So that means that we get to
confuse the types returned
from the functions in
certain places like a and b,
we no longer have
precise information.
We do this so that our
type analysis finishes
in a reasonable amount of time.
The third interesting thing
about the type of analysis
is that it's path sensitive.
If we were to call
something where
we believe that an
integer's flowing in,
we look-- oh, I
do have a pointer.
Good.
When we come to this add site,
we've got a set of three types
here.
But we know that int
doesn't have an add method.
So that we know that if we were
to actually run the program,
passing in 35, it would
throw a no such method
exception at that point.
What that allows us
to do is to do a trick
that we call receiver
type strengthening, where
we can eliminate int
from the set of types
after that, because
it would have thrown.
The fourth trick that we do
is at some point, we give up.
If we are adding too
many types to our set,
it becomes less and less useful.
So to avoid taking a
lot of memory and time
doing that, we say, OK, we'll
make it an approximation
to the set of types.
In this case, we could
say it could be anything.
At that point, we also
unfortunately lose
some of the power of the
receiver type strengthening.
Because there are many classes
which have an add method,
so the set of classes
which have an add method
is too large, so we say that
could be anything either.
So what's happened here
is in our type analysis,
we've pushed the types
around, the types
are sloshing around our
program, and we have not really
learned anything useful.
So because we didn't
learn anything useful,
first we need to have
that two level dispatch
with getInterceptor
at the call site.
And the second effect
is at that call site,
because we think
x can be anything,
we think it could be any
of those add methods.
So it looks like
all of those add
methods could be called
from that site, which
means that we need to
include those add methods
in the program.
This is how you get code
into the program that
isn't actually called.
There are a few tricks that we
use to try and prevent this.
I've told you about just
receiver type strengthening.
We do conditional strengthening,
they're obvious stuff.
If you say x is string,
we know it's a string.
And then we have
a sister analysis
tracing where, for some
values, we can trace them
precisely where they go.
If we can pull that off and
know exactly where they go,
we know a lot more.
For example, if vector
is not overwritten here,
we would know that it's
always of length 2,
and we'd be able to
eliminate bounce checks.
So what can we do knowing
how this type inference works
to help?
Well, we can do some kind
of defensive programming.
Can we do that to improve
our type inference?
So consider this example.
We have a Printer class.
It has a items field, which is
initialized in the constructor,
and we have one core
site which passes
in a list, which is represented
by a JavaScript array.
If we give Dart or
JS this program,
it does a really good job.
It knows that in the
for loop, for example,
this is a JavaScript
array, and for in can be
compiled to an indexing loop.
Now if you put on your
black hat and say,
how can we ruin our day
with a type inference?
Well, you could add some code
to program somewhere else
in a different library
that assigns to a field,
you have a new class
in there, and you
assign to the items field.
Now, if the type
inference thinks
that junk could be
anything-- and we
could see how easily
that could happen-- then
it has to account
for the fact we
could have that
spurious inclusion
effect with the setter that
assigns to our field here.
So now the compiler
has to assume
that items could
be a list or a set,
and that means that
our for in loop
now will be compiled to a
standard iterative loop,
and will need to use
the two level dispatch
with getInterceptor
to find the iterator.
You can fix that problem
by putting up a bulkhead
to stop the type sloshing
around in your program
by using privacy.
Dart has library
privacy, so the names
that begin with an underscore
are private to your library.
And you can use
that to protect them
from another library reaching
in and affecting your code.
So what you do here in
protecting your program, what
you would think of as normal
programming best practice,
is also helpful to
the type inference.
Because it could also use
that partitioning of the names
into the libraries
scopes as a way
of knowing that there is
less types sloshing around.
However, anything that you
can do with two libraries
to ruin your day,
you could probably
do in a single library.
Maybe you've got this
nice large library,
and you have in there
multiple classes
which all have an items field.
And the type inference
comes to the conclusion
that junk could be anything,
we're back to the same thing.
But now we're in
the same library,
so we can't use library privacy.
So what should we do?
Well, we could
use a final field.
If your class is such that
you only initialize it,
and you use a final field,
this is a very strong hint
that the type
inferencing can use.
Because there are very few
paths for setting that field.
So I'd like to sum up on this
and talk about names a bit
here.
So in a sense the names
connect parts of the program
inadvertently.
If you partition the
names in your program,
you'll get better
type inference.
A sane way of partitioning them
is to break your program down
into more libraries so
that you can insulate them
against each other.
An insane way is to invent
a complete new terminology
for naming everything.
It's not really helpful
if you have something
which you want to be
a standard collection
to have a completely
different set of names,
so I avoid doing that.
But it is something
to think of if you
know that there is a problem
in your program with that.
So up until this
point, I haven't really
talked about a program that
has types written in it.
In Dart, when you
have a declaration
and you used a type
in that declaration,
that's called a type annotation.
It works rather
like an assertion.
What that means is,
in checked mode,
that type will be checked
at that point in runtime.
So when I assign to s, there's
a check which says, OK,
is this a string, or no?
If we've done that
check in type inference,
then we can proceed
from that point knowing
that s is a string, or no.
In production mode, those
assertions are turned off.
What that means is that
we can actually not
make any assumption
about s if we
want to execute the program
as a correct Dart program.
Because Dart, the
language, will try
to do the best to call the
methods that you call on
s regardless of what type
was sitting there and being
ignored in the program.
However, you use all
these great tools.
You've got the editor.
The analyzer, which
gives you warnings.
You have to your test framework,
so you run your tests.
And presumably, you run
your tests in check mode.
So this kind of production
mode where you ignore the tests
doesn't really
make a lot of sense
if you're running
those tests already.
So we added a flag to the Dart
JavaScript compiler, trust type
annotations.
It's basically checked
mode without the checks.
It makes sense to
use it if you're
using all of the tools
available to you,
and also that you don't
swallow type errors.
So you know for sure that
when you run your program,
you've got great
coverage, great test
coverage, no static warnings.
That's great.
So you might say, Stephen, you
just told me about this type
inferencing, and
now you can say,
well, I can just put types
in and say believe them?
That doesn't really
help with everything.
There's a few things that we
can't say in the type system
that we have today.
We can't say whether
something is null or not.
It's been a request for a while.
If you look, it's got a very low
bug number in our database, non
nullable types.
Knowing whether
something's null or not
is actually quite important
for generating good code
with arithmetic.
If in Dart you say
null plus 5, you
get a no such method
error on null.
If you say 5 plus null, you get
an argument error on the null.
If you run that same
code in JavaScript,
you get some crazy result,
which doesn't really make sense.
So we don't have a
nice way in the type
system of finding whether
something's null, so type
inference is the
way that we might
discover something is null,
then generate the good code.
So it's still
necessary for that.
The next thing is,
we don't really
have a way of saying that
something is a JavaScript
array.
On the VM, it's never
going to be a JavaScript
array, your list type.
List is an interfaces that's
implemented by many classes.
And just saying that
something is a list
doesn't really give us a way to
avoid that two-level dispatch.
And furthermore, we don't
really get a lot of help
from those tests with
the type parameters.
Just satisfying
the type assertion
that something is
a list of string
doesn't guarantee that the
things in the list are strings.
Declaring something
as a list does
help with spurious inclusion.
We know that DateTime
is not a list,
so therefore, we don't
need the DateTime method.
We don't have to add that.
So I've told you about some
things that you can do,
now I'm going to tell
you about some things
that you might want to avoid.
Now, I'm going to preface this
by you might want to avoid
when you're shipping your app.
But these are
features which can be
very useful in your unit tests.
So I'd like to think that
when your app is in dry dock
and you're testing
out the subsystems,
it's OK to have a situation
where the types might
slosh around the program.
It's just when you want
to compile your final app
and deliver it to
your customers,
then you might want the
benefit of the optimizations
that we get from having
the better type inference.
All of these features
are things which
make the type of
inference's job much harder.
The first thing you might
want to avoid is mirrors.
Reflection isn't really
difficult for type inference.
The problem is
that something here
where you're calling
reflect and invoke,
it's very hard for
our type inference
to see what the type of o is.
It doesn't know
what the name is.
This looks like that spurious
inclusion on steroids.
This call here looks like I call
every method with one argument,
and that argument
could be anything.
So our recommended
approach to avoiding that
is to use code generation.
And we've been switching
a lot of our libraries
to use code generation.
We have smoke package,
reflectable and polymer
all use code generation.
The great thing that you can do
when you generate code is you
can put type
annotations in there
which you can check,
and then trust later.
The second thing to
avoid is no such method.
If we consider this
line of code here,
if we don't know what
the type of junk is,
it could be anything.
When we call that
trim method, that
will require to have
that two-level dispatch.
In our type inference, we
can look at that trim method,
and we say, OK.
I receive a type strengthening,
there's only one class,
at least in the core libraries,
that has a trim method,
and that's string.
So we know that if trim
succeeds, we had a string,
and we returned a string.
Now that we know
we've got a string,
we can compile the
rest of this expression
into essentially the same
code that you see here,
but in JavaScript.
Very nice.
If we have a class that has
no such method-- for example
this proxy class here--
usually the no such method
implementation does
something really clever,
and the type inference can't
figure out what it does.
So it says, OK, that no such
method returns anything.
So now when we look at that
trim method, what can we say?
Well, we know the trim
could be string.trim,
which returns a string.
But the other method we could've
called is proxy.noSuchMethod,
and it returns anything.
So after we come
back from trim, we
don't know anything
about that result,
because it could have been
some crazy thing returned
by the proxy.
So we have to do that to level
dispatch again for toUpperCase.
And the same thing happens
there in our analysis,
so we have to do the dispatch
again to call equals.
So this basically,
by having this proxy
in our application in some
library that we didn't even
know that we were including,
takes this one line of code
which had one
two-level dispatch,
and everything else
was nice JavaScript.
It turns it into three of
those dispatches, which
will make it slower and bigger.
So because it's not always easy
to find where these things are,
we added some hints to .js.
If you put on the verbose flag,
and there are implementations
of no such method in your
code, they will be pointed out.
A final thing I'm
going to suggest
is don't use runtime type.
Most of the time when you
write a generic class that
has type parameters,
those type parameters
are used in type assertions
and not really anywhere else.
So in checked mode,
those types are used.
But in production mode, or
if you're trusting types,
those type parameters
are unused.
So we have an optimization,
which is if they're not used,
why bother to pass them around?
So we analyze the
program to see where are
those types actually demanded?
And if they're demanded, then
we followed that path of demands
to make sure that we
pass the types along
when they're needed.
Which is usually not much.
However, the runtime type
getter returns a type object
that has one useful
method to string.
And that method requires the
type parameters to print them.
So if you include the runtime
type somewhere in your program,
then now it means
that every usually
you're calling it from
somewhere where you don't
know what the receiver is.
Because why else
would you want that?
So don't use runtime
type, because it
inhibits this optimization
of our type erasure.
So like I said before,
these are three features
I said don't use.
They're fine in testing, but if
you want to shift the best app,
they interfere with that.
So .js is a work in progress.
We're always looking
for things to improve.
The type analysis is something
that we would like to do.
We'd like to improve that.
We would like to make better
use of the inferred types,
and we're also looking
at ways of making
the two-level dispatch when we
still need it, cheaper as well.
OK.
So I'm done with this, so I
guess we have the questions.
Oh wow.
How long do I have questions?
MALE SPEAKER: 40 minutes.
STEPHEN ADAMS: 40.
MALE SPEAKER: You have 3 and
1/2 hours for questions now.
STEPHEN ADAMS: I got 3 and
1/2 hours for questions.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: No, you've got--
STEPHEN ADAMS: Do we were want
to take the questions right
now?
MALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, we have time.
I think you started
a little earlier.
STEPHEN ADAMS: Oh, I did.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]--
MALE SPEAKER: Here.
You're close enough,
I'll hand you the mic.
I'll be the mic runner.
AUDIENCE: So you said if
you're using run time type,
there would have to be split
to pass that type information.
What about is, same thing?
STEPHEN ADAMS: If
you use is, then you
can see where that is is.
So then we can
trace back from that
where is is-- I sound
like Bill Clinton.
We can trace back
from where the is is,
to where did that
type come from.
And only the types that
passed a type parameter along
to that point need the type.
AUDIENCE: So it's a bit safer?
STEPHEN ADAMS: Mm?
STEPHEN ADAMS: Yeah,
it's a lot safer.
Because it's only
the paths which
lead up until that type
parameter that are included,
yes.
So if you have a
class where you, like,
a checker class of a type
parameter, where you then
say I've got this checker of
int, and checker of string,
and those are the type
parameters, that's pretty safe.
Because there's usually not a
complicated path going there.
But by a path, I mean, like,
if you have list all of t,
and then that returns
a list iterator of t,
then in the list iterator, you
used t, you didn't is check,
then that would
trace back from the
is checked in the
iterator back to the list.
And then so at the point
you create the list,
you'd need to pass it along.
So both the list iterator
and the list would need t.
But it wouldn't mean that,
say, a set needed it,
unless you had also is t
in your set it iterator.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Adam?
Wait, actually.
AUDIENCE: So what's
the story when
you use trust type annotations,
and libraries and modules
in code you don't own?
Can you scope where those
trusting of annotations
come from?
It does not need to
make sense at all.
STEPHEN ADAMS: Yeah.
That's a great feature request.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyone else?
Coming around to you.
AUDIENCE: How well does the
analyzer work on futures,
and does it work any differently
if I'm using the async 0.8
syntax?
STEPHEN ADAMS: OK so that's
a very good question.
One of the things that we're
doing with the Dart development
compiler you heard about
in the previous talk
is looking at when we can
believe the generic types more.
So part of that is, what do
we have to have in our program
that we could actually
believe the generic types?
And I think that is mostly
that we always use them
on the path to somewhere.
So in that case, we might
be able to say that,
OK, in my then clause
when I'm using a future
that I could know that
type is the one that I
got from the type parameter.
What you could do today--
I mean, we really wanted
to do this, because it's
very common to write then,
open parens, identifier
and that's it.
And our style guide is not
to put a type in there.
But if you do put a type in
there and you use trust types,
then I don't know how well
the analyzer picks that up.
Hopefully it knows--
MALE SPEAKER: It's OK
to say I don't know.
STEPHEN ADAMS: Yeah, Yeah.
We'd like to do
much better at that.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyone else?
Someone in the back, you
can ask a question just
to watch me run
around like an idiot.
STEPHEN ADAMS: You can find me.
When I wrote this talk, it
went an hour and a half.
So I've got many more examples.
MALE SPEAKER: If you wonder
what can primitive flag,
that's a secret if you
ask Stephen afterwards.
STEPHEN ADAMS: That's not as
important as the trust types,
though.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
STEPHEN ADAMS: OK.